okay let's now get to the reaction from
a whole bunch of different people
including donald trump himself to the
absolutely
explosive revelations the claims being
made in the forthcoming book from bob
woodward and robert costa as we told you
in an earlier segment
the chairman of the joint chiefs general
mark milley was so worried that in the
aftermath of his loss to joe biden and
the january 6 riots
that donald trump was so
out of it that he would actually maybe
try to launch nuclear weapons and we
learned about in the book we learned
about the things that mark milley did in
order to try to prevent this including
having some kind of fail-safe type
conversation with the top military brass
phone call with uh chyna uh phone call
with nancy pelosi etc well donald trump
appeared on newsmax yesterday on the
show of
sean spicer his own former press
secretary
and
saying a lot of really crazy things
let's just jump right into it so first
of all if it is actually true which is
hard to believe uh that he would have
called
china and done these things and was
willing to advise them of an attack or
in advance of an attack that's treason
now it would only be advising them in
advance of an attack if this story is
true and trump was really thinking of
nuking china i mean understand now trump
in a moment will deny it but think about
what trump is saying trump is saying you
know if we're doing an operation a
military operation of some kind
including a bombing and you go and you
let the enemy know ahead of time that's
treason
but in order for that to be the case you
have to be saying that it's true which
now which trump now says is not true
anyway and i would think i've had so
many calls today saying that's treason
number one number two it's totally
ridiculous i never thought of it you
were there you were you knew what was
happening in the world if you never
thought of it then what millie did made
sense which was assure china
that you're not actually about to nuke
them so which is it i mean even the
explanation is completely incoherent you
have plenty of friends you never heard
the word china mentioned in a thing like
this you heard a lot of anger about
china on trade and we made a great trade
deal you heard a lot of anger in china
with the china virus the trade deal was
a disaster there was no deal it was
tariffs that were completely
counterproductive remember just to be
thorough but uh
for them for him to say for him to say
that i would even think about attacking
china i think he's trying to just get
out of his incompetent withdrawal out of
afghanistan the worst the dumbest so
remember that was trump's withdrawal
plan first and foremost trump's
withdrawal plan uh but if there was
really no plan or even worry that you
were going to go after china
then it's really no big deal for millie
to say guys we're not going to nuke you
we're not going to nuke you it's okay
don't worry so it's a it's a
flip-flopping trump's furious
for conflicting reasons both of which
can't possibly be true thing that
anybody seen probably the most
embarrassing thing that's ever happened
to our country where they
they killed our soldiers
they we left with embarrassment
so now trump's on to afghanistan by the
way yes we left americans behind and we
left 85 billion dollars worth of the
best equipment in the world that i
bought
because i was the one that rebuilt our
military and then biden gave it that's a
lie as well a way for him to say that i
was going to attack china is the most
ridiculous thing i've ever heard and
everybody so again milli is not saying
trump was going to attack china millie
was saying
we were worried he might
lash out and try to launch nukes
but we believed we had a plan to prevent
it and we assuaged the fears of china
it's like trump trump he's
misunderstanding the story three
different ways
and responding to it in three different
ways that are conflicts with each other
does he know it no does sean spicer know
it or care probably not he knows it and
i have to tell you i don't know if they
have him on tape saying this but i found
woodward and i found
his cohorts to be extremely dishonorable
people that's why i didn't do an
interview with him i think he's highly
overrated this guy is one of the most
overrated guys he's a sleaze but i did
not ever think of attacking china one
other thing i just read a report about a
week ago where they said donald trump
was the only president in decades that
didn't start a war okay so that
an often repeated phrase that out of
context and without any serious analysis
means very very little so
trump everybody's terrible the reporters
are sleazes the the general is a
lightweight note the constant ad
hominems and attacks here trump drops in
during the interview without evidence
that obama is actually probably
currently in charge not joe biden he's
the opposite he's worse than obama of
course obama is probably running the
government now anyway according to many
yeah so a former president saying it's
actually it's a different president the
president that's officially the
president's not really the person that's
in charge okay that's there's a former
president saying it um and then lastly
here here is donald trump with a sort of
completely delusional framing of the
perception of america's place in the
world
the people of our country respect us
they love our country and they want to
see our country succeed and our country
has gone really downhill in the last
eight months like nobody's ever seen
before now remember
the polling is
respect for america globally is up
basically everywhere russians liked
trump
there i don't remember there's like one
african country and then also maybe
turkey where trump had like okay
approval and respect around the world
everybody else was disgusted by trump
globally respect for the world is up
now that trump is gone it's the opposite
of what trump is telling you and you go
to these elections that are coming up in
22 and 24 we're not gonna have a country
left the election was rigged and we're
not gonna have a country left so a final
lie there as donald trump signs off so
trump
highly triggered by this report which in
all likelihood
is true at least in the spirit even if
not every single detail um can be
independently confirmed that that's sort
of my sense of it the book is well cited
and well researched and we're going to
continue to learn more about it
one of our sponsors is nebia who have
developed the most impressive shower
head i've ever seen it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water and what
they created the nebia bimon spa shower
uses 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head but with an 81
more powerful spray and they do this by
using atomized droplets that rinse soap
and shampoo off faster than any shower
head i've ever used i installed nebia by
moan spa shower in my bathroom at home
took five minutes to set up i've been
using it for about a year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head the nebia by
moan spa shower starts at just 199 but
you'll get 10
off all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com pacman and use the promo code
pacman the link is right underneath this
video